the greatest lesson i've learned  throughout my career came from maya  angelou actually  when i was you know first meeting her  and uh  after i'd known her for a while she said  baby you know  you need to know that when people show  you who they are  you believe them  the first time  oh you know that lesson too now  first time and uh your problem is it  takes you 29 times to see the same  lesson coming in a different skirt or  wearing a different pair of pants so i  think that has been one of my  greatest wisdom teachings is to  assess  uh from people's behavior their actions  not just towards me but towards other  people  uh who they are and how they behave  because if people talk about other  people they'll talk about you so i think  in business and in personal  relationships that's also been my  greatest lesson